&gt;&gt; Well, if no time has passed, then we start with $200. That's how much was
initially in our savings account. We know each month we save exactly $100. So,
after one month I would have $300, and then, if another month goes by, I save
another $100, and we can easily fill out the rest of the table. But remember, in
algebra, we want to know for x number of months how much money would we have.
Well we start with 200 and then we multiply the number of months by 100. So we
also need to add 100x. Now we've related the amount of money we saved with the
number of months, x. We have this equation, y is equal to 200 plus 100x.
Congrats if you got this right. I know this isn't the easiest algebraic
reasoning, but if you work from a table and build it up, you can get here and we
can switch these two terms around. I could have the 100x come first, followed by
200. This is the same equation.